and guess what the final margin was
three points and we're off and it's a
king's Gambit
love it I love this choice of opening
already it has given Magnus a very big
Advantage he's gonna Pawn up with a
great attacking situation and uh I think
Andrew Tang kind of uh he just pre-moved
into this so that that this has worked
fantastically well the extra Pawn is an
extra Central Pawn as well and um you
can attack on the F far so uh a very
crafty opening Choice that's there Robin
and Andrew he used the pin on the C file
before he could have taken the D4 Pawn
so he had the right idea wrong execution
and now Magnus remains a pawn to the
good this looks fantastic for him and
there's too much pressure going on the
e-file the queen on E6 is loose the
Knight on D5 will be hanging if you take
on E5 and The Rook takes back hitting
the queen and the Knight beside it so
this looks like a winning advance from
Magnus on the clock and on the board
and you know what I like best
Magnus is singing can
I kept on mute Magnus and hear what he's
singing and we me and Robert can just
chill out and just hear hear the great
karaoke star in his own environment
that's that's what I'd like to see he's
got his headphones on he's tuned in and
he's getting into the vibe here well we
might have to wait for that but this is
something Hikaru does I mean is Magnus
getting tricks mikaru getting his
singing voice out Robert do we think do
we know if Magnus you know can sing a
little bit and he does so many things at
a top level he's the number one Raider
chess player he was the number one in
fantasy football soccer I mean fantasy
football is a very American thing so
let's call it soccer just for ease but
he was number one in the world in that
too so maybe he's secretly a great
singer
come on I mean it's a bit sickening he's
you know he's good he's just too good at
everything he's got to give other people
a chance right I mean you can be world
champion the chess but you're not
allowed to be good at everything so I'm
gonna say he's a terrible singer just to
make myself feel better so he has a
great position now right now so whether
his singing is good or not doesn't seem
to be that important and Knight D1 that
turn it around because the queen and the
Rook are both under attack and you can
see I'm magnus's face he's like oh what
was I thinking there
yeah a little bit of overconfidence
there and that has given Andrew
um a good decent well decent position
he's the exchange up five second lead on
the clock though for Magnus and Magnus
position is is quite well I was going to
say quite solid but now Andrew is broken
through on F7 so
um really good fight back from Andrew
oh what a final madness he SATs his
Queen temporarily and look at the clock
Magnus is up over 10 seconds he should
just flag his opponent
yes he's got to I mean Andrew's going to
try flagging him enough times in this
and uh not easy to flag though okay oh
look at that Andrew oh no that was sorry
he stole his Rook because Andrew felt
like he had a pre-move every turn he and
Magus brought his Rook back Magnus was
actually going for a draw there if the
Rooks were traded it would have been a
draw so it's interesting to note that
Magnus maybe not trying to shamelessly
flag his opponent you have to go for the
dirty flag but he was able to get the
job done because of his leading the
clock
it was and he's played the king's Gambit
again uh this time Andrew was expecting
it and we've got a pretty standard
position in the king's Gambit when you
win your Pawn back white has the extra
Central Pawn lots of pieces remain on
the board I love what the white Knights
are doing here jumping straight in uh
but okay the computer really liking the
two Bishops here and there goes one Pawn
so the king's Gambit this is magnus's
secret weapon so far yeah Bobby Fischer
I used to love himself a good King's
Gambit and another world champion
decades later Magnus Carlson says I'll
do the same we know he's no longer world
champion Dania also was like wait world
oh sorry excuse me former world champion
Magnus Carlson it's so easy to forget
but oh he just forgot that his Bishop
could be captured so he didn't win the
exchange and did you see his reaction
there
wow that that was just yeah that was a
big mistake you can't make too many
mistakes like that and even though you
say Magnus is not the world champion oh
he's won the queen back there it's all a
bit messy he's kind of like the world
champion in our hearts isn't he he's the
strongest player I think he might isn't
he still rapid world champion or Blitz
World Champion he's well championed at
something I I failed to believe he's not
and um the reason why you didn't
remember which one is because the answer
is both and he also just won this third
game in a row so he can't stop won't
stop winning
yeah of course thing is the world
champion we know this and a very well
deserved world champion is but uh kind
of due to Magnus not taking part isn't
it as well I'd love to see ding play
Magnus at a future moment hopefully that
will happen
uh but Magnus is the speed world
champion
okay so he's got a nice lead uh a
massive lead is there any way that uh
Andrew can come back from us
um yes definitely like in the overall
match I definitely believe you hesitated
you hesitated the reason is because I
thought you were asking me about this
specific game and you know I look at
this position and this looks like a
king's Indian gone completely wrong for
white and looking great for black and
you see the capture on G4 leaves the E4
Pawn hanging this is a dream come true
for Magnus
yeah this is a beautiful position
completely uh completely agree if you
look at Black's pawns piling through and
um the white king incredibly exposed
here at the same time I mean still just
about hanging on but that F Pawn is uh
getting very close to becoming a queen
as well
um
queens of the board still hanging on
there's a nasty fret of Rook swinging
over in some positions here as well
I don't think there's anything that can
be done and another win for Magnus he
seems to be on good form
it's scary good form when ferrugia said
that Magnus needed to level up I think
Magnus is officially leveled up like
this is
ridiculous thus far four straight wins
and convincing ones at that leading on
the clock throughout most of the games
he's hasn't been worse in his positions
very often and now he goes to a setup
where he has his Bishops both fianchetto
and now the board's opening up for those
very Bishops Advantage magnets they're
ever so slight Advantage but still I
like the bishop pair
yeah the Bishops are looking quite good
now and he's got he's swapped one
advantage of Bishop paired to a better
Pawn structure now and the reason this
is a better Pawn structure is Black's
pawns are rigid in the middle and that
one there the Magnus is attacking is
very weak the one on D5 so it's very
subtle advantages and one thing that is
clear about Magnus is is will I mean to
be a champion like he is it's not just
about your talent the amount of work you
put in you've got to have the an amazing
will and you want to win everything and
that will to win is gonna you know after
he lost to faruga it's gonna be shown
um in these upcoming matches and I would
not like to play an angry Madness oh he
he wants some kind of like he might go
king of one at some point oh he just
Rock drop he drops his Rook wow he's
blunder The Rook after I say that
and Andrew gets that win uh but I think
what you're saying is true because when
he beat Eric he was upset that he'd give
Eric any points he wants to win every
single game he plays he has you know the
heart of a champion but also he's got
the hunger of a lion he really wants to
win every single game that he puts I
don't even know if lions are that hungry
like can someone who actually knows
about animals tell us our lion just
seems like kings of the Jungle or are
they actually also hungry all the time
because Hungry Hungry Hippos was a game
I never played hungry hungry lions
I reckon lions are hungry they've got to
be they're big they're big they're big
cats aren't they and I'll tell you one
thing my cat is always hungry always
eating far too much
um so they've got to be they've got to
be hungry
um and I love the way we we sometimes
progress away from the chest it's nice
to have a look break because I get a
headache otherwise with the amazing play
on the board and this is so complicated
this position uh I mean the white king
looks really exposed but white is a
piece up
any result possible here yeah I thought
there would be almost a Checkmate but
the knights are protected and there it
looks like a pin down the C file but
there's a light score Bishop in the way
but Simon clock and King safety both in
Black's favor and roast C4 picks up not
the D4 square but this Knight on e4
yeah and this is the thing even though
uh White was probably winning somewhere
if you have the initiative it counts for
so much at this time limit and now it's
equal initial material and that white
king is getting absolutely teared apart
here and uh I doubt it can survive is
there a killer blow just taking a rook
all of a sudden Magnus is a whole Rook
up
did you see the way you played that
it's one check that wasn't even just
like oh I'm gonna try to flag my point
that was the best move so Magnus I mean
he really is in charge of the match
right now
yes just dominating the match at the
moment I mean when Magnus plays like
this
there's not many people who have a
chance
um against him
Andrew's got to pick up his game he's
got to get some wins on the board there
is 20 minutes to go often these matches
go in swings but another strong tactic
there from Magnus Knight C6
and this is simply going up a whole rook
and he won that game in a matter of
seconds
phenomenal play and I love this comment
from fractured sword this is like
watching Messi play Simply Sublime and
as an American welcoming Messi to the
Emma lesson into Miami that should be
fun but yeah watching Messi played
throughout his career has been a treat
for everybody and watching Magnus when
he's informed it's a treat for everybody
except for his opponents because I don't
think Andrew's having the best time thus
far
no I mean it's not enjoyable when anyone
tries to smash you but look at that that
is a beautiful move from Andrew
absolutely stunning Vision I love that
the whole point is the white Bishop can
check the black king and then it can
pick up the the queen in the middle
Magnus counter strikes now so you have
to be a little bit careful and Andrew
spending his time but that just shows uh
how strong Andrew can be and how quickly
he also spots tactics oh Andrew Tang is
world class and I think when we are
looking at this match we will always
acknowledge that and Magnus just happens
to have jumped out to a hard start and
he's trying to run away with his King so
considering he lost his Queen but he
lost it for a night and a rook he does
have compensation he's worse and now
he's gonna drop another Pawn in the
center but I'm looking at the clock and
maybe black is even better because of
the time
yeah it's true and the Black Knight has
now secured itself in the middle of the
board and uh the only way that white can
probably win this is by using that past
Pawn which he has shoved up the board uh
but the clock will be important if
there's anyone else I'd be backing black
but Andrew is pretty well known for his
speed and that should secure the game
nice that was a brilliant win from
Andrew we need more of that he's got a
nice point on the board and let's see if
he can uh keep get a roll going he needs
to get a role going now
Point very well taken that Andrew you
know when he has even a Time deficit how
quickly he plays it's a sight to behold
and he was able to win that game he kept
enough time on the clock and found the
killer blow and in this game Magnus just
this guy's playing this slowly he's
giving away a pawn to open up some lines
and Bishop takes D6 Queen takes C6 to
follow the E6 Pawn will be tender
I think Andrew did the right thing being
brave uh yeah you're right though this
is the oh lovely or nearly it was close
oh my God does it work I'm just shocked
at all moments when moves like that
happen like here's the queen A4 I wasn't
even looking in that direction I was
looking along the C file and well
Andrew's done well to hold on here the
Knight takes F5 that's a good shot from
Magnus but
what in the world of an opposite color
Bishop Rook end game where White's Pawn
structure is better
yeah yeah I mean that again it's going
so so quickly I mean white is better
here because White's got the potential
to get a past Pawn so you see the pawn
on the right hand side uh okay it's
still a little bit better for white but
should be a draw there goes the past
Pawn
gonna come down to the clock like extra
extra lot of time for Magus but I I feel
that 50 moves should better should be
made here in time yeah yeah and they
actually repeated the position three
times and I was going to say if the
colors were reversed I think Andrew may
be able to get that job done and flag
Magnus but their moves were so easy to
play just move your king back and forth
and so it pre-moves were available and
now in this game we get a London system
Andrew Tang's specialty and so far looks
pretty normal I think black has escaped
the opening without any disadvantage
whatsoever
yeah
and here comes the black pawns uh moving
down the board
uh I mean that's the other thing about
you know um I would say like uh Grandma
so I don't mean that with any disrespect
but not a world champion and uh Andrew
is nothing he's not a regular Master
that's a wrong thing to say but someone
who hasn't played in World Championship
matches magnus's openings are just so
good because he's prepared for so many
of these big encounters with a team
behind him and he's able to swap in and
out of certain openings and uh he should
be okay in most positions I I say that
though he is playing 186 quite a lot in
this match
um which is a very peculiar opening to
play and here is black attacking again
Robert
it looks like that to my eyes but Andrew
is stopping that attack by playing in
the center that's often how you combat
somebody who's going after your king and
I just want to quickly follow up what
you're saying that as regular
Grandmasters ourselves no I think we we
know what you mean that our opening
preparation oh gosh that's a blunder of
an exchange there on E3 but even though
some games some openings oh there's a
mouse slip by Magnus and he gets away
with it because Andrew was pre-moving
and a little smile out of Andrew but we
get away with things in individual games
some moments openings but on the whole
people who play in the candidates in the
world champion matches their opening
preparation is much deeper and better
and Magnus he's looking to pick up this
game with the black pieces he's a rook
against a bishop those pass pawns are
stopped Simon this looks like a win for
Black based on how much time remains
yes another Point
um just just racking them up at the
moment even after a mouse slip there uh
yeah I mean it's just a show of class at
the moment and the way that Magnus is
playing
he loves having the two Bishops as well
magnus's little things in his games you
will see happen time and time again and
uh I I think maybe the stronger you get
as a player the more you appreciate
having the two Bishops that's why I like
having the knights because I find them
trickier and here you can see those
Bishops working very well to win The
Exchange
black has some attacking chances here
though and what Magnus just Blended a
bishop on F5 with check yeah he is not
gonna happen and H6 is an important move
because Queen takes B4 there are back
ranked threats so right now Andrew isn't
charged in this game on the board and on
the clock but finding The Knockout not
so easy here because if the Queens come
off the board winning from there will be
far from simple
yeah
you've got to win this one the white
king very weak get your dark Square
Bishop maybe G6 is a move here or G5
that'd be quite uh maybe it doesn't work
so well now getting on the dark squares
I agree with what you said about keeping
the Queens on when you've got the Knight
and Bishop versus The Rook you want to
keep the Queens on the board generally
because they're great attackers and I
think now it will be Magnus resigning
and he does because the queen was about
to check White's King and uh it's just
too exposed there and we gotta just
resign from Simon and you were a spot on
Simon Says and it happens and this kind
of position I feel like is nice in
bullet the one we're seeing from the
white side here A7 just dropped so
Magnus didn't take care of his a pawn
and now it's off the board and the
advantage very heavily in Andrew Tank's
favor in this game
it is but look at that a file I mean oh
straight in with a tactic does that work
or does it Bluff another thing I've
noticed is that Magnus does bluff
occasionally you know when things go a
little bit wrong he will play a quick
move confidence and because he's Magnus
Carson his opponents won't always take
you know capitalize on that
yeah you believe the former world
champion and the number one reader
player in the world for such a long time
now I think that I believe that Andrew
will win this game as he is two nights
for a rook in the position he's about to
gobble up the queen Side Pawn and now
his passer just runs
there's still a chance I mean it's not
all over it's seven and a half to three
and a half uh there's 12 minutes left
Andrew is now getting into a bit of a
rhythm uh he's playing really well uh to
you know just to get points on the board
against this uh this you know
horrendously strong player and if he
wins this one well you know it's still
doable still possible he needs to win
this one because Magnus is trying to
catch up on the clock but finally the
Rooks under attack the G6 Pawn the B6
Pawn is passed so that was a resignation
Andrew gets it it's a three-point
deficit now and Magus he shows that hey
there are times where he missteps and
Andrew was able to scoop up that Bishop
on F5 with check and then win the game
yep important when that is getting a bit
more into the match now Andrea's
confidence is growing and you need to
have that
um in this one we see Magnus playing
with a knight instead of the bishop
but he has a nice compact Pawn structure
no weaknesses in White's position and
maybe Black's pawns are even a little
bit overextended there you go one Pawn
drops and there could be some more
exchanges here but is that a pawn gonna
drop it does drop so a pawn up for
Magnus clean pawn and this King on G1 if
queens were on the board we said maybe
black can get an attack on the light
squares but without Queens on the board
there's no checkmating threats and F3
stops all that before I can even finish
my sentence about it
and the next stage here would be able to
oh he just he just blundered there oh
the mouse slip
Four Points in it
yeah
Mouse lips they happen especially in
bullet we saw Dania drop his Queen in
front of a bishop and lose that earlier
because of a mouse slip so none of these
players they're it's not a foreign
concept to them but probably a moment
that Angela can I Mouse slip later today
not in my magic it's Magnus Carlsen
yeah
you always Mount slip when it's the
worst possible time as well I found you
know you don't Mouse slip on like Mount
move one where it doesn't matter it's
always when you're you're winning and
you drop a queen
um and here well again look at Black's
pieces black has one one a piece for
that pin and the black king is very safe
so there's not really any compensation
and that's why Andrew resides just to
get on with the next game I love the use
of the Kings Gambit I I play the king
I'm one of the only Grand Masters who
still plays it you mentioned Bobby
Fisher playing the Kings game I think
the most famous world champion was Boris
basket he won every single game he
played in the Kings game played against
great players
um and you can play these openings still
even at the top level yeah I mean Magnus
and ikoro also he dabbles with the
king's Gambit and played it for a long
time but this is terrible this is why
you don't play the Kings game but it's
because the king is still in the center
and black is happily up a pawn and you
could probably just start taking things
and the Knight on e4 is in trouble this
is just game over
it should be yeah um Bishop G6 a class
move yeah it is it is game over Robert
you're right and uh a nice little touch
early in really good play from Andrew
he's spotting uh spotting the tactics
there very quickly
is now a clean exchange with the safer
King and Magnus he shouldn't resign and
he's taking a drink of water he'll
probably let his time elapse look at how
much time is left in this match eight
minutes and now about to be 40 seconds
he did resign as soon as I said that he
resigned
he could have let that time go
he is super confident uh Robert you know
I mean he he he just wants to win more
games he he's he's confident in his
ability uh he's thinking I don't need to
do any of these tactics I'm just going
to win more games and I want to know
what he's singing at least we've got a
question for the interview right uh what
music is he listening to
and what's he singing anyone got any
predictions in the chat oh you do Magna
say he's listening to you know you're
asking for it Simon by getting the chat
involved about what he's listening to we
even got some funny answers yeah but I
am actually curious yeah different we
heard Bortnick say he likes to listen to
rock music and just different whatever
he's vibing to at the moment but right
now Magnus in this game up and outside
Pawn King very safe the e-pawn advances
and those hanging Pawns in the center
they can be strengths if you can get
them going and they take away squares
from enemy pieces but they can also be
dangling and weaknesses
yeah and it's weird there's too many
nights in this position for me to better
work out what's happening but there goes
the exchange uh even though the exchange
has gone Black's nice they're holding a
lot of squares
very good play so far from there there
it goes um Andrew wins another one so
he's keeping himself just about in the
match and Magnus was really unhappy
about that I see that Michael Jackson uh
shout out there Guardians of the Galaxy
music
see I you told you you just get
ridiculous answers
yeah I know I was asking for it as you
said there Robert a little bit too much
wasn't I so I was setting myself up
Barbie girl I've seen it he's listening
to his stream that's a really good
answer by Friday
5D
okay we see him in this game using
tactics a little bit more
um and
um just to run the clock down now the
six minutes 46 and the score is free in
it so okay Andrew needs to win a game or
two to make this make this uh
interesting and no more love this
opening yeah no more this is this yeah I
would say no more King's Gambit but he
sacked a piece this is your style
this is actually supposed to be pretty
good for white and I I was thinking why
did why did in the previous match uh
this wasn't tried out because G6 is a
little mistake A3 actually sets up G6
and the sacrifice it's kind of a very
weird delayed Halloween Gambit idea
um and now it's equal material and
there's a big check with the Knight
misplacing Black's King but this also
looks like a decent way to play Black's
pawns are are horribly uh distorted here
I also love what Magna did there he just
lost the advantage by his follow-up
decisions but instead of going for a
Checkmate or a check that may not have
mounted them much he just ruins the
Pawn's Pawn structure but Andrew now if
you push this Pawn to C3 then the queen
comes into A2 and you're just going for
checkmate Queen into still a great move
the C2 Pawn is loose this looks
residable
yeah this is this is a chance and it's
only gonna be two points in it this is
where even if you are Magnus Carson you
start to get a little bit nervous you
don't want to lose this big lead and uh
you can see I think he he swore a little
bit there he's letting his time go down
he's readjusting Andrew has a chance
he's back in the match there's five
minutes to go remember you need to win
by two points and if Andrew takes the
next one well it's game on
I'll be cutting it to one and now you
see no more 1a6 uh he stopped probably
gonna stop playing the king's Gambit uh
going forward uh Magnus is not like this
is getting too close for comfort now I
need to give my full focus and play more
Mainline stuff and I don't think Andrew
knows this line nearly as well as Magnus
does
nice very hard to know the highest as
well as uh you know Magnus he has his
team of workers and this this is a very
interesting idea and if black can stop
white from castling it could be a
disaster
and yeah he puts pressure on that night
so if White Castles he captures it and
now white can't Castle so White's King
is walking a tightrope but what happened
there well Magnus blunder a piece uh
Vicky just like he just lost a piece his
night was under attack
uh or you know the piece of before
excuse me was under attack against
didn't move it that was strange
look at his face Robert oh if if Andrew
can keep this together which oh no it's
getting messy
Rook B one oh
he's fought back into the match
white is completely tied up here
wow this is a big big game Robert I feel
it is yeah because if Andrew won it
would be a one point match but now
Magnus he's head bobbing he's trading
pieces if he wants to he's also up over
20 seconds
yeah this is a massive game because the
difference for this one was as you said
it could be one point in the match or
three if Magnus wins and Magnus wins to
take it to three points meaning that and
look at him he gives a little laugh
there realizing he's very lucky meaning
that Andrew must win this game now with
the black pieces and maybe the next game
as well I mean this is this is a must
win scenario isn't it this game he needs
to win this one and he needs to win the
next one and he doesn't have a choice in
the matter so uh from the black side of
this position it looks like you know the
pawn structure not particularly good for
either side but the C7 C6 Pawn is harder
to get to that pawn on F3 in particular
down the road that could be a real
weakness that white has to defend
yeah and I love what uh Black's done
with the night there the Knight finder
great Square Rook takes Knight is a
threat
it's a Magnus sacrifices first here
and
black has chances in this one chances to
get that important win which he must win
yes but the f file that's going to give
black a lot of the action over the
Knight on D3 that is one of the best
place pieces you could possibly ask for
yeah and those two pawns also Robert
they're coming through the board aren't
they I mean uh two connected pass pawns
very scary here and
The Rook now has to give way to the H
Pawn with okay maybe more maybe that
could have been played better yeah what
a fine though King G6 but now Knight F4
kicks the king away H7 Falls and oh it
doesn't mean 96 rookie seven
I think that could be it you can see
Andrew shaking his head there there's
only two minutes left and uh yeah Magnus
giving a little cheer there he realizes
he's through and maybe a little sigh of
relief
I was gonna say the same thing that
you're about to say so please finish
Simon
I I was gonna I just think I was gonna
say I don't think Magnus be 100 happy to
win a match when but I don't know it's
sort of hasn't been that clean
and I think that's why he celebrated
because if he was going to win this
match by a large margin but yeah okay
another day at the office but the fact
that Andrew gave him a serious fight and
there was some odd blunders and things
of that nature you know even in bullet
odd for Magnus I think that you know he
felt like he was on some rocky uh
terrain and well even in this game like
he was doing just fine and suddenly he's
dropped upon an end game and his Pawn
structure is bad so it has not been a
perfect performance by any stretch of
the imagination but that's who Magnus is
even when he's not playing perfectly
he's still beating stars like Andrew
Tang by several points
yeah I I mean he's done what he's done
enough I think in this one but
he needs to play better than this if
he's going to beat Hikaru I would say uh
you know if we do see a Magnus Carson
Hikaru final I think Magnus will have
played a little bit better because
hikara is just he's not going to show
any Mercy and he'll have to play better
on this to beat Dania tomorrow right
this yes the way he's played in this
match I mean Dania beat Andrew tank by
eight points and of course things change
day to day and match by match uh but the
way Don has been playing in this event I
really think that Magnus will have to
improve his play and while I don't know
if this last game maybe it's off in time
it doesn't change the match Victor that
is Magnus so yeah this game has
concluded they stopped it and Magnus is
like hmm why I'll play another one
yeah
I mean uh
yeah okay well Andrew's resigned that
one realizing there's no point it's not
gonna affect the match at all and we see
Magnus winning that one
um and you've got a little bit closer
one moment but I the the stronger player
did win uh throughout that match uh
Magnus was always ahead and uh yeah
pretty pretty good performance there